good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
let's get right to it do rich people
have better Wi-Fi or just be honest they
have to unplug her router sometimes
interesting fact money can buy you
almost anything but it cannot buy you
freedom from Comcast
I'm pretty sure Beyonce answer reset our
router just like the rest of us how do I
cope with the fact that there's no real
meaning in life oh man I wish we could
go back to Beyonce questions so listen
maybe meaning in life is constructed by
us rather than derived from some
objective truth but that doesn't make
meaning not real okay so you should
always be suspicious of people who use
metaphor to approach questions of
meaning however imagine you're walking
through a forest one night and you come
to a clearing and you find an eternal
fire it's the perfectly sized fire and
it doesn't need anything from you you
don't have to put wood in it it just
burns and burn and you can spend your
whole life seeing by its light and being
warmed by it and so on I think that's an
awesome fire and if you find one you
should be grateful but imagine that you
don't imagine on your travels you never
come across an eternal fire in that case
you have to build a fire and then find
fuel to keep it going and sometimes
it'll go out and you've got to start a
new fire now in some ways that's worse
but in some ways it's better because
unlike the eternal fire you understand
how and why it works point being I would
argue the light and heat from both fires
are equally real all right that's all I
got no more questions about the meaning
of life will you come to my wedding in
September my partner he's obsessed with
you and your wife
so when Sarah and I got married we
invited a somewhat famous person who
shall remain nameless to our wedding he
wasn't like a close friend but he was
someone who'd had an important role in
getting us together and we thought it
would be nice to invite him so anyway a
couple weeks after the invitations come
out I get an email and it begins of
course I cannot come to your wedding
what do you mean of course is there a
less necessary of course in the history
of the English language would not I
cannot come to your wedding have
sufficed anyway he did buy us some wine
glasses off our registry which we still
have so thank you right but to your
question of course we cannot come to
your wedding I'm kidding if it's in
Indianapolis and there's an open bar
we'll be their favorite fictional
depiction of time travel I like your
implication that there are non fictional
depictions of time travel probably for
me back to the future which has had kind
of an outsized influence on my life is
there going to be another season of
crash course literature
yeah probably what should we read I want
to know everything about your new book
but sadly I don't know everything about
it because it's not finished yet are you
tired of people asking about your new
book no it's nice that people
I just wish I had something more to tell
them what's your favorite River
definitely the White River here in
Indianapolis even though Indianapolis is
a city of a million people the river is
really beautiful and mostly deserted
like you can kayak for hours without
seeing anyone and the reason it's so
beautiful is that it's basically a
heavily polluted open sewer and by
basically I mean it is ghosting so it
seems natural and pristine precisely
because it is so unnatural and polluted
it's just a very metaphorically resonant
River favorite online server to store
and organize information nice try
hackers but not this time do you like
the number 53 it's probably in my top
half of two digit number 43 is the best
though you ever go by any nicknames well
some of my friends from high school
still call me cuffs because I once said
that Christian Slater never made a bad
movie a few thought mean consciousness
so like I spend probably the majority of
my free time thinking about whether I am
actually comprised of my thoughts and to
what extent the thoughts that are called
mine actually belong to me but I haven't
come to any meaningful conclusions why
do people become so obsessed with being
right rather than developing richer ways
of thinking I don't know I'm trying to
practicing I don't know more because it
seems to me a really underutilized
phrase hey what's in the boxes behind
you I don't know when your new book
gonna come out I don't know if your
greatest hope and your greatest fear
challenged each other to a duel who
would win so who would win a duel
between absolute oblivion and a cure for
malaria I don't know take this I don't
know stuff is amazing the life-changing
magic of I don't know Hank I will see
you on Friday actually I don't know for
sure that I'm going to see you on Friday
but I hope I do